this is a white-footed Mouse in Lyme
Connecticut this is the bacterial
disease inside the mouse in Lyon
Connecticut these are the deer ticks
sucking the blood of the mouse that has
the bacterial disease in Lyme
Connecticut this is the tick that's full
of the blood that's full of disease that
came from the mouse in Connecticut the
deer tick swells to twenty times its
original weight before dislodging itself
from the mouse
[Music]
this is the Deer Tick one year later
it's full of the bacterial disease that
came from the mouse and now it's looking
for another host a white-tailed deer
this is the deer tick
climbing the plant that's near the deer
and also near humans if humans get
bitten by this tick and contract its
disease they could get arthritis and
even cardiac problems the deer tick is
an arachnid a member of the spider and
scorpion family and while it doesn't
have eyes it does have these tiny
sensors at the tips of its limbs that
can sense the heat and carbon dioxide
given off by a potential victim likes
some antibiotics are in order this is
the man that just got the disease that
came from the tick that sucked the blood
of the mouse that had the disease that
lived in the town that shares its name
with the disease Lyme disease Lyme
Connecticut